cette reprise d'activité avec le
déconfinement du 11 mai un bol d'air
pour une partie du tissu économique
yvelinois fortement impacté par les huit
semaines de confinement pour en parler
jerram h liébaut jour bonjour président
de la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
des yvelines alors avant de parler de la
relance quel bilan provisoire
faites-vous des conséquences du coc vie
de 19 sur la situation économique dans
le département alors dans notre
département l'activité a été moins
touchée que pour le reste de
l'ile-de-france puisqu'on à une baisse
d'activité d'à peu près 60% alors que
pour le reste de l'ile-de-france a été
65%
c'est d'ailleurs le même constat pour le
chômage partiel puisque les demandes de
chômage partiel concerne 45 % des
entreprises dans les yvelines
alors que pour l'île de france cela
concerne 60 2 % des entreprises donc
nous sommes plutôt favorisé dans les
yvelines
j'irai dans cette phase difficile et en
fait les demandes de chômage partiel
c'est à peu près cent seize mille
demandes d'indemnisation pour les
entreprises des yvelines qui représente
à peu près 85 millions d'euros
donc qui ont été distribués alors bon
c'est dire et les entreprises des
yvelines c'est surtout les services et
tout ce qui est commerce hôtellerie
restauration bien sûr qui a fait ces
demandes de chômage partiel et j'espère
que ça va donner justement pour certains
ça va ça les a bien aidés de plus au
niveau du fonds de solidarité qui a eu à
peu près 30 6 millions d'euros donc qui
ont été demandés pour le fonds de
solidarité ça représente à peu près 1000
352 euros par part entreprises avec des
versements d'après ce que disent les
entreprises des versements assez rapide
il y a normalement à deuxième volet donc
de ce fonds de solidarité et il ya très
peu de monde dans ce deuxième volet
puisque il ya actuellement que 5000
demandes sont dans ce deuxième volet
c'est bien sûr également les mêmes
d'entreprise c'est-à-dire commerce
hôtellerie
événementiel services qui ont fait ces
demandes et je crois que donc c'est
aussi ce qui concerne le tourisme qui
est bienvenu actuellement c'est les
annonces du premier ministre hier
concernant justement les aides prévues
pour le tourisme le tourisme en a bien
besoin parce que je pense que les
activités touristiques ne vont pas
reprendre tout de suite et il est
important justement que on est
particulièrement le tourisme la
restauration l'hôtellerie l'événementiel
ce sont des activités importantes au
niveau des prêts garantis par l'état
il y à peu près 5588 près que tu ai
demandé dans les yvelines qui représente
à peu près 900 millions d'euros dont qui
ont été demandés avec toujours des
remontées de frilosité des banques qui
peuvent effectivement demandé des
prévisionnels qui sont impossibles à
donner pour les entreprises est bon la
bonne nouvelle c'est effectivement que
tout refus en dessous de 50 mille euros
doit être notifiée par par écrit par la
banque
hélas beaucoup d'entreprises devraient
faire appel au médiateur du crédit
lorsqu'elles n'ont pas lorsqu'elles ont
des refus et bien sûr la cci est à leur
service pour pour les aider alors le
dernier point c'est par rapport au
tribunal de commerce
bizarrement il ya très peu de donc de
liquidation tribunal de commerce la
moitié des députations habituel et puis
il ya bien sûr aussi très peu de
d'immatriculation je pense que le
tribunal de commerce attend à une
influent d'arrivée justement de dossiers
à partir de septembre octobre et je
crois que il a raison je crois qu'il y
aura beaucoup de dossiers qui vont
arriver à partir de cette date
malheureusement malgré lé déconfinement
malgré le déconfinement parce que
beaucoup d'activités n'ont pas repris
vraiment complètement et je pense qui
malgré les aides malgré de déconfinement
bon bon d'après d'après le président du
tipnis du tribunal de commerce il
il risque d'y avoir beaucoup de
difficultés parce que il sait aussi qu'à
des entreprises
qui était pas dans des situations très
facile justement avant la crise comment
s'est passé le déconfinement dans les
entreprises yvelinoise quel regard vous
portez justement sur le dé confinement
et la manière dont les entreprises se
sont organisés ben je crois que ça se
passe plutôt bien
on a moins de problèmes de transport
dans les yvelines bien sûr puisque et je
pense que ça aussi ça milite pour une
déconcentration des activités en ile de
france vers la grande couronne moi c'est
je pense que justement la crise montre
qu' il faudrait déconcentré un petit peu
les centres où tout le monde s'agglutine
et avoir une déconcentration vers la
grande couronne
il ya bien sûr la problématique des
masques des gels des protections
l'organisation du travail qui est
constitué un coup supplémentaire pour
des entreprises en particulier pour le
btp et il ya des difficultés pour
certains métiers justement btp bien-être
beauté pour pouvoir mettre en place les
mesures barrières
il y en a bien sûr nous les chambres
consulaires donc chambre de métiers
chambre de commerce et d'industrie on a
participé la distribution de masques qui
ont été attribuées par le conseil
régional d'ile-de-france masque donc
attribuer gratuitement et qu'on a
distribués depuis deux semaines donc les
distributions se font au commerce aux
tpe pme aux artisans
le medef est hélas et là ces pme ont
également participé à ces distribution
de masques donc ça permet à certaines
entreprises peut-être pas tout d'avoir
en tout cas des masques pour une
quinzaine de jours et pouvoir
fonctionner sur quinze jours après le
commerce au niveau du commerce qui est
l'inquiétude justement parce que ils
risquent avoir une moindre fréquentation
parce que bien sûr les clients hésitent
pour venir pour aller dans les commerces
encore
et puis il ya le cas des centres
commerciaux des centres commerciaux donc
jean mode et maison qu'ils sont et one
man one nation qui ont ouvert qu'en
permis donc qu'ils sont ouverts mais il
malgré tout donc fait d'idées parly 2
qui font plus que quarante mille mètres
carrés compas pu ouvrir ça peut créer
des difficultés pour les commerçants
justement de ces centres commerciaux et
on espère justement qu'ils auront les
autorisations assez rapide justement
pour pouvoir ouvrir parce que pour ces
commerçants c'est quand même très
important
merci gérard bacheliers je vous en prie
président de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines